لقد أصبح الرمز الأكثر محاصرة
للاحتلال الروسي في نهاية هذا الأسبوع، حيث
قالت موسكو إن هذا الحادث كان مجرد
ستار من الدخان لإحباط هجوم أوكراني
على جسر كيرتش الذي تبلغ تكلفته أربعة مليارات دولار، وهو
الرابط بين روسيا وشبه
جزيرة القرم المحتلة، والذي يبدو أن بوتين شغوف به.
الآن حصلت CNN على لقطات حصرية
يبشر بطريقة جديدة للحرب من خلال
غارة أوكرانية مدمرة أخرى بطائرة بدون طيار محمولة بحراً هناك في يوليو من قبل
أجهزة الأمن الأوكرانية، جهاز الأمن الأوكراني
الذي يقول إنه فعل ذلك وسيتبعه المزيد،
هذا هو بالضبط ما رآه طيار الطائرة بدون طيار
الصور الحرارية للمياه تموج بما يصل
إلى  طن من المتفجرات يقترب من الجسر، ومن
الواضح أنه مات عندما
اصطدم بالخرسانة.
قال مسؤولون روس إن مدنيين
قتلا في كاميرات الهجوم على الجسر التي
التقطت الانفجار الأول على
قسم الطريق، ويظهر المؤشر طائرة بدون طيار
تتحرك
وآخر على السكة الحديد.  المسارات في
نفس الوقت تقريبًا،
كانت أوكرانيا تقول إن بعض المسؤولين
يقولون إن هذه الانفجارات الضخمة هي من
أجسام عائمة مجهولة الهوية، لكن لم
يعد رئيس
خدمات الأمن الأوكرانية يقول لشبكة CNN، إن هذه مجرد
بداية
للطائرات بدون طيار على سطح البحر، وهي اختراع فريد
من نوعه لجهاز الأمن في أوكرانيا.  أوكرانيا
لا تشارك أي من الشركات الخاصة في
استخدام هذه الطائرات بدون طيار، لقد
أجرينا مؤخرًا ضربات ناجحة
لجسر القرم وسفينة هجومية كبيرة
أولونجورسكي جورنياك وناقلة سيج،
وهذا هجوم أوكراني آخر بطائرة بدون طيار على
القارب الهجومي البرمائي الروسي أوتوناجورسكي جونياك الذي
وضع عليه المسؤولون الأوكرانيون  كان على متنها مائة فرد،
وكان هذا إنجازًا رائعًا قام به
أسطول متنامٍ مما يسمونه
أطفال البحر على بعد
مئات الأميال من
القواعد الأوكرانية وفي قلب الساحل الروسي مباشرة،
مما عرض البحر الأسود شرقًا للخطر. فجأة
يتم إنتاج هذه الطائرات بدون طيار في
منشأة إنتاج تحت الأرض في
أوكرانيا،
نعمل على عدد من
العمليات الجديدة المثيرة للاهتمام، بما في ذلك في
مياه البحر الأسود،
أعدك أنها ستكون مثيرة
خاصة لأعدائنا، براعة
أوكرانيا مرارًا وتكرارًا في
الإطاحة بجالوت الروسي المتثاقل،
نيك بايتون والش، سي إن إن دينيبرو أوكرانيا